aujourd'hui on va parler d'une image
choisie par l'historien julien neutre et
grâce à son travail
on va voir ensemble comment cette image
a impacté la ville de rome par le cinéma
de fellini
[Musique]
voici anita ekberg les yeux fermés le
cou tendu vers le ciel au coeur même du
bassin de la célèbre fontaine de trevi à
rome
plongez dans les stalactites de pierres
blanches du bassin elle paraît ici comme
une sculpture une de ces saintes en
extase qui plaisait tant oberlin le
sculpteur de la rome baroque
cette image choisie par julien neutre
est tiré de la scène culte du film la
dolce vita réalisé en 1960 par federico
fellini
le film est largement récompensé
puisqu'il reçoit une palme d'or un oscar
et il devient le plus gros succès
italiens de tous les temps à ce jour
jamais égalé mais ce que nous fait
remarquer julien d'être ici ce que pour
cette scène fellini pourtant créateur de
génie n'a rien inventé du tout mais là
directement été inspiré par son actrice
en août 1958 deux ans avant la sortie du
film
anita ekberg se fait photographier dans
la fontaine de trevi
devant le regard ébahi des passants et
des policiers qui n'osent pas demander à
la star de sortir d'un que la baignade
soit interdite
elle porte une robe longue en coton
blanc et rose dans le haut ressemble à
une chemise masculine et quelques jours
plus tard les photos apparaissent dans
tous les journaux
c'est comme ça que fellini les repères
pour le rôle des andes elle la star
internationale dans son propre rôle à
nice bergues dans le rôle d'anita ekberg
qui aurait pu mieux faire la faire elle
l'a fait elle peut le jouer
la fontaine de trevi est un des
monuments emblématiques de la ville
éternelle
son originalité sa situation au sein du
dédale baroque la disposition
scénographique de l'ensemble on ne
viendrait à rome que pour ça et
aujourd'hui la fontaine de trevi est
connu dans le monde entier comme celle
du film de la dolce vita mais personne
ne se souvient de son architecte nicolas
salvi c'est d'ailleurs depuis la sortie
du film en 1960 que la pièta dit rêver
reste constamment rampe et touristes ils
sont si nombreux qu'il est devenu
difficile de se promener près de la
fontaine pour l'observer est impossible
d'y être seul en 1994 pour les 100 ans
du cinéma
la municipalité a fait projeter la dolce
vita sur l'eau de la fontaine de tri et
à la mort d'anne d'icebergs une
banderole chao anita fut même déployé
sur la fontaine alors en rénovation
ce que nous explique julien neutre c'est
que si la fontaine de trevi et anita
ekberg
reste une pièce essentielle de
l'imaginaire de la capitale italienne
c'est grâce au travail de fellini et ses
salles alchimie du cinéaste de faits
divers triviaux effet un chef-d'oeuvre
du cinéma d'une image ordinaire il fait
une nouvelle mythologie d'un monument du
passé il fait un lieu de vie d'une star
de papier glacé le symbole de la vie
éternelle
fellini disait rangs mc rae alors à mon
tour j'ai créé rome
[Musique]